come
uh oh 10 50 10.50
okay he's 10.50
[Music]
59. see if you can speed up get way
ahead
so you can get way ahead and and set up
sticks again
yeah i ain't got sticks in my car
i'm gonna go to the 44.
right
y'all able to block him in
he's trying to hit us as we get around
him
yeah number 44
we're coming up on the 44 and a half now
get one person
i'm trying to obtain permission from ceo
to shoot the tires out if that's an
option for y'all
[Music]
we are 44 north now coming under the uh
round
[Applause]
[Music]
where's the stick that
is long you might need to move out of
the way so you can get sticks
i'm in a bad life
[Music]
shots fired shots fired shots fired i
believe i gotta hit him
yeah
you are here
from me call me
[Music]
he's trying to continue
again okay
[Applause]
somebody else do the call me somebody
else do the call
i think i got him
the driver i think i got the driver
i probably shot about six seven times
john are you good i'm good all right
he didn't shoot
i shot no i'm
[Music]
somebody else got to take this boys
do not come over this way you're in
crossfire do not come over the bridge
john will you need a minute we'll
relieve you if you need
yes
[Music]
he just ran over my foot
stop
stop
stop
we did it intentionally behavior
he did it intentionally vehicular
assault
all right he just went into the pacific
pride park
we're going through the business
[Music]
avenue
right now
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
positive contact
[Music]
you're getting on a motorcycle
oh
so
all right